[Musique]
il est député les républicains de l'oise
il préside la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale
bonjour eric woerth bonjour alors nous
sommes ensemble pour une interview de 20
minutes et on va commencer par
l'actualité forte de ce jour la nouvelle
étape du déconfinement qui doit être
dévoilée par le premier ministre edouard
philippe
cet après midi qu'est ce que vous
attendez des annonces du premier
ministre
j'attends un peu plus de déconfinement
un peu plus de liberté plus de liberté
au travail l'ouverture des restaurants
le passage de nombres j'espère dans ces
fameuses zones vertes c'est à dire son
hub est remise
trois de ces gens on ce que disent un
certain nombre de médias qui sont bons
démis a plutôt tendance à se calmer dans
pas mal de temps le notamment le mien de
l'oise n'était pas été très touchée et
le joue dans le haut rhin 10 ans la même
chose donc vous mettre au clair dick est
clairement eu à retravailler également
trouvé un lien social
c'est beaucoup couru j'attends aussi les
lycées 1 avant de l'est alors eric
woerth on va voir et bien cet après midi
la nouvelle carte de france avec les
zones rouges et les zones vertes
il pourrait y avoir une classification
par département et non plus par région
ce serait une bonne solution
je pense que je vais je ne sais pas
comment d'un construit les choses par
par région mais on voit bien que c'est
aussi une affaire de mobilité dans la
région n'est autre ans il ya une très
grosse différence entre le département
du nord est le département de l'oise le
sud du département de l'aisne et c'est
vrai beaucoup de beaucoup de régions
donc je crois qu'il faut être beaucoup
plus précis avoir probablement la
précision qu'il ya eu au début de
l'épidémie avec cette heure
mieux qui pour une raison ou pour une
autre été très affectés et infectés
d'ailleurs par un virus
je crois qu'il faut en revenir sans
doute à cela
et puis il ya la question des transports
c'est très important est évidemment que
les transports tous être libérés un peu
plus fort plus de temps et plus de bus
de métro dans des conditions acceptables
parce que s'il ya plus de gens qui vont
au travail
il faut évidemment plus de transport
pour respecter les distances et puis
faire sauter cette barrière 200 km n'a
plus de sens mais alors justement à
propos des transports est-ce que vous
pensez que même avec un trafic à 100% et
bien les travailleurs pourront revenir
normalement au travail c'est très
compliqué n'est qu'il aimerait de
trouver le bon équilibre entre une
protection évident sur le plan sanitaire
et puis le fait de revenir à une vie
normale et que geste de prendre ou
individuels que tout le monde est
maintenant par coeur mais il faut le
faire c'est les on dit tout dans le
rythme zéro n'existe pas moins dix fois
par jour
mais c'est vrai il ya un moment donné
les viviers pour la legal team et tous
les ans et mais il faut vivre avec son
protégé cibles protégées les périodes
il faut rendre la vie voilà la vie qui
gagne
alors est ce que finalement l'enjeu
principal de cette nouvelle étape du de
confinement c'est la relance du secteur
du tourisme vraiment frappé par cette
crise du cornât virus mais la relance
par tous la relance par tous on ne peut
pas être à la traîne d'une d'une relance
vous commencez à avoir parlé tout à
l'heure et donc la relance par tous
alors évidemment le secteur du tourisme
des quatre dernières fois on ne peut pas
a été particulièrement affectée par te
mendoise dès le début en avant ont pas
vraiment du truc ce fait sont très très
sérieuse donc il faut évidemment que
c'est plus que les conditions
économiques acceptables crois qu'avec la
protège celui de 9,1 décapité restaurant
pas retenu année jeudi accepter ou
d'établissement et pour les faire ouvrir
leur encore plus d'argent
ouvert 6 pas parce qu'on va justement
pour relancer le tourisme
à propos de la limitation des
déplacements et de ce fameux rayon de
100 kilomètres selon vous est ce qu'il
faut supprimer ce rayon ou le desserrer
et élargir la possibilité de se déplacer
encore une fois au gouvernement d
information et c'est vrai alors des
genres donc je voudrais pas dire de
bêtises mais merlus 100 km c'est ce qui
est fixé devès pourquoi c'est artificiel
coût des places chez papa et puis on
évite les brassages de populations ou
sans doute distance ayant fait l'effort
pourquoi d'accord le gouvernement nous
autorise mais ne pas partir en vacances
voilà vous habitez en soi mais c'est la
même chose
oui d'abord ouvrir ce stade ci il était
midi le père mais s il a dit que si
important mahmoudi en mal gens le
traitent avec goût et jean veil
le principe de précaution et devient un
steam
alors vous le disiez les signaux
sanitaires sont plutôt positifs
actuellement est ce que selon vous le
déconfinement était plutôt bien gérée
par le premier ministre je pense que le
déconfinement et pour bien jouer oui oui
il était annoncé pour enfants et les
mesures d'aidé économique ont été ont
été prises les transports aussi je
puisse comprendre je peux comprendre et
je comprends qu on tâtonne dans ce type
de comme d'autres pays l'ont fait mais
on ne peut pas t'étonner trop longtemps
dans la reprise économique c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que plan de soutien
de survie de l'économie ou d'une
économie artificiellement arrêté doit
succéder à un moment donné un vrai plan
de relance cohérent qui soit pas
uniquement égrainer au fur et à mesure
des secteurs mais dans lequel on puisse
voir une cohérence d'ensemble une vision
d'ensemble de ce que pourrait être
l'économie française dans les années
qu'ils ont parlé dans un instant de ce
plan de relance économique
mais avant cela un mot sur votre
département l'oise qui était dans un des
premiers grands foyers de l'épidémie de
coronavirus en france comment va la
situation sanitaire actuellement c'est
évidemment infiniment meilleur qu' il y
à quelques quelques semaines le
département de l'oise devrais je pense
en tout cas je l'espère pouvoir basculer
dans ces départements vers il était très
très touché et très très tôt les mesures
de confinement ont été bien respectées
les départements sont quasiment mise à
l'arrêt mais ces mises à l'arrêt bien
avant des séminaires dans les hôtels
beaucoup dans la bordure sud une bordure
très touristique les séminaires se sont
arrêtés les hôtels en quasiment perdu
tous leurs clients dès le début du mois
de mars et de la fin février
alors dans cette nouvelle étape du
confinement la nouveauté ce sera la mise
en service de l'application stop
qu'ovide de traçage numérique des
citoyens pour casser les chaînes de
contamination le parlement à l'assemblée
nationale et le sénat ont voté hier pour
la mise en service de cette application
mais les députés les républicains dans
leur majorité était contre ce dispositif
pour quelles raisons enfin je si c'est
utile pour le pour la pole pour la lutte
contre contrôler l'épidémie il faut le
faire mais il fallait le faire avant
dans ce cas là moi j'ai mes collègues et
comme beaucoup d'autres personnes qui
ont voté pour que là dessus a pas de
vérité moi j'ai beaucoup j'ai beaucoup
de craintes sur les libertés publiques
on voit bien que c'est un débat qui a
pas eu lieu complètement il a eu lieu
mais pas totalement il ya eu vraiment
l'économie
il ya eu la santé il ya quand même aussi
les libertés
public et ses applications et bien
d'autres sujets amène à se poser
beaucoup de questions sur le risque et
les libertés et je vois bien que au fond
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin sur la
base du volontariat tant mieux c'est
évident à voir absolument nécessaire on
va ça veut dire aussi que l'efficacité
sera sans doute très moindre et pas
vraiment pas vraiment pas vraiment au
rendez vous les pays qui l'ont mis en
oeuvre l'on me en un an neuf bien avant
et d'une manière bien plus brutale c'est
d'ailleurs parce que je demande
mais mais mais je crois que toutes ces
applications dont on domine pas bien les
choses dont l'homme de la rue que je
suis dans ce domaine là aussi ne domine
pas bien moi je ne sais pas combien de
temps ce sera archivé où nous dit ce
sera archivé du tout bon fond n'en sais
rien donc tous ces sujets je relaye et
qui sont des craintes au fond sur la
société du numérique
ces craintes la elles sont fondamentales
pour notre liberté les libertés
publiques donc à partir du moment où ce
n'était pas un outil absolument
fondamental pour éviter la reprise de
l'épidémie
je pense qu'il valait mieux ne pas le
faire et se concentrer sur autre chose
alors les députés les républicains ont
voté contre ce top cow vide mais au
sénat la majorité les républicains du
sénat a voté pour cette application leur
président le président du groupe l'est
républicain au sénat bruno retailleau a
même dit je cite que c'était un devoir
de voter pour ce dispositif pourquoi ces
divergences entre les parlementaires et
l'air est ce que les députés ont fait un
peu de politique politicienne
c'est regrettable c'est regrettable tepa
dans les conversations entre bruno
retailleau et d'amis là bas nous de
temps en temps il peut y avoir des
opinions différentes sont pas
fondamentales l opinion sur les libertés
publiques et la mène et le pignon
évidemment sur l'ensemble de la crise
est aussi la mère sourde et poum cette
nature peut avoir on peut avoir c'est le
verre à moitié plein et le verre à
moitié vide
l'application stop qu'ovide ci a aucun
risque qu'il faut et il faut le faire si
on considère qu'il ya un début de
risques que ça pose une question de
libertés publiques
il faut pas le faire c'est pas très
grave
leur temps à parler maintenant de la
relance économique d'abord au plan
européen puisque ça y est on connaît le
plan de relance européen présenté hier
par la commission européenne
750 milliards d'euros qui intègre les
500 milliards d'euros du plan franco
allemand qui avait été annoncé par
hemani
macron et angela merkel c'est une
victoire pour l'europe ça y'est l'europe
est au rendez vous de la crise du cornât
virus alors oui un ami de temps pour
être au rendez-vous comme souvent parce
que l'europe c'est lourd c'est compliqué
il ya des positions très différentes les
unes des autres
si un plan important je rappelle que le
budget européen c'est moins de 150
milliards tout le monde pense que c'est
un énorme budget en fait c'est un tout
petit budget c'est le très inférieur au
budget du pays est obligé de la france
ou de 750 milliards c'est une faune
présents pour prendre et ce qui est bien
c'est que dans 6 750 milliards il ya 500
milliards ils sont pas des prêts aux
états classique mais qui sont des
subventions issues du budget européen
est financé par un emprunt mutualisé
dont pas un emprunt européen
c'est bien la première fois et c'est l
annonce du président mâcon et de la
chancelière merkel il ya pas longtemps
donc ça c'est un pas en avant qui est
assez fondamental
on verra quelle est la distribution de 6
à quel comment vont ses subventions dans
quels secteurs dans quels domaines et il
ya quel pays on verra on verra tout cela
elle sait si loin d'être encore apprécié
mais je pense que c'est une
c'est une bonne chose ça vient s'ajouter
au dispositif qui avait été décidée par
l'ordre notamment par exemple le soutien
au chômage partiel et la france aura
bien besoin d'un soutien financier pour
pour essayer de sorbet la dépense
considérable de l'activité partielle
enfin en tout cas leur a appris les
bonnes les bonnes décisions et on peut
s'en réjouir
il y ajoute les décisions de la bce
alors allons maintenant sur le plan
français est ce que le gouvernement
français est au rendez vous de la
relance économique
selon vous à on verra on verra ce que ça
donnera on verra si sûr et dans une
courbe très très plate de relance ou au
contraire une courbe très vigoureuse de
relance aujourd'hui le prévisionniste
preslois en réalité une récession de
l'ordre d'une dizaine ou d'une douzaine
2% pour l'année 2020 dont c'est
absolument gigantesque c'était énorme 12
% en 10 % de récession c'est d'ailleurs
c'est plus du tout les chiffres qu'on
donnait le gouvernement c'est des
chiffres absolument gigantesque on peut
mettre des années à remonter la pente
c'est ça qu'il faut voir même si vous
reprenez 5 ou 6% l'année prochaine vous
serez très très loin
de la situation autant 0 avant avant la
crise donc le revenu et ressource la
création de richesses seront treize ans
en retard il ya des plans sociaux qui se
profile dont certains sont d'ailleurs
concrètement concrètement donc on voit
bien que le risque est une reprise assez
lente
avec évidemment un cortège de plans
sociaux et des licenciements est dedans
de personnes qui vont passer d'un
chômage partiel à un chômage réel et
c'est ça qu'il faut absolument éviter
et c'est de cela dans le gouvernement
est au fond responsable et comment il va
articuler cette économie de survie qui
était ce plan de survie qui était le
plan de soutien gigantesque qui crée
dans beaucoup de déficit mais qui était
obligatoire qui était plutôt bien
construit
comment on passe à une une économie de
reprise ou en accélère la reprise
économique
et pas uniquement en la constate au fil
de l'eau est également où on en fait un
accélérateur de transformation
économique je pense notamment à
l'intégration de données écologiques ou
numérique ou de nature alors eric woerth
la semaine prochaine vous présenterez
votre propre plan de relance de
l'économie française est ce que on peut
déjà connaître les premières pistes
combien d'argent il faut mettre sur la
table pour relancer la machine
on y travaille depuis trois semaines on
a déjà sorti des papiers déjà bien avant
que le gouvernement ne pas réellement de
durlin on le fera plus collectivement la
semaine prochaine à propos des niches
comme on dit dans des ppl de l air à
l'assemblée nationale donc il ya un
premier point c'est qu'il faut vraiment
effacer ces trois mois donc il faut au
maximum et essayer de 2,2 des greta dire
d'abandonner les créances de l'état en
interne fiscales et sociales toutes les
cotisations sociales ou la fiscalité qui
a été due elle est reportée pour dans
beaucoup de secteurs et dans la
d'ailleurs dans la plupart
il faut absolument que l'état à mon avis
il abandonne à partir de leurs
proportions par exemple de la perte du
chiffre d'affaires donc c'est absolument
essentiel parce que les entreprises
n'arrivons prendre pas à payer leurs
charges du moment et les charges du du
passé il faudrait que les choses soient
soient très claires faut aussi me
semble-t-il activer les dépenses de
chômage partiel et puis à un moment
donné faut que les salariés acceptent
même si elle des risques et ils
acceptent d'aller travailler à un peu en
télétravail mais surtout en présence le
physique et puis de l'autre que les
employeurs acceptent de les reprendre
plus vite que la croissance de leurs
propres chiffres d'affaires je pense
qu'il faut réduire le coût du travail et
donc il faut ponctuellement donc il faut
que une partie des déchargeurs et des
coûts de chômage partiel soient
transférés vers une baisse du coût du
travail je pense surtout aux jeunes
aussi nous on en parle depuis presque un
mois
de cette génération qui risquerait
d'être une génération sacrifiée
on voit que beaucoup de monde est en
train de le découvrir les portes de ce
stage se ferment les apprentis n'en
trouve pas ce qu'ils veulent nos jeunes
sont enfin études trouvent porte close
sur le marché du travail il faut trouver
des solutions alors par exemple à zéro
charge pendant deux ans pour l'emploi de
jeunes sortant de leur de l'heure de
leur formation doit être pourrait être
une solution bien d'autres peuvent
exister exister quand y'a pas d'autre
solution prolongé par exemple le statut
étudiant qui assure une protection
sociale etc revoir peut-être la notion
contrat à durée déterminée on peut
peut-être le rendre un tout petit peu
plus ou dans un moment donné sans tomber
dans les erreurs du passé donc sous ces
sujets sont majeures puis un autre sujet
qui est majeur c'est que les entreprises
elle doit être super endettés y'a pas
que les états qui vont être super
endettés les entreprises vont être super
endetté le club le bg e ce plan
garanties par l'état
c'est un endettement en font des
entreprises donc il faut au maximum et
si et convertir de l'endettement en
fonds propres ou quasi fonds propres
pour assurer la survie des entreprises
eric woerth pour financer ce plan de
relance de l'économie financer tout cet
argent public qui va être injectés dans
la machine économique est bien dans le
débat actuellement il y à la question de
la contribution des plus aisés le
président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand a même mis cette
proposition sur la table en augmenter la
contribution des plus riches
et puis la prix nobel de l'économie
esther duflo la même assuré il faut un
nouvel impôt sur la fortune si c'est le
prix nobel de l'économie qui le dit il
faut l'écouter non pas du tout non il ne
m'aime pas
ils fondèrent la recherche économique
ifo pas de l'application économie quand
on l'a 65 millions d'habitants en face
c'est très très différents même si le
respect pour les économistes la
dimension sociale d'un plan de relance
d'un programme de relance et l'ex
fondamentale et dans un programme de
relance on doit évidemment intégrer tous
qui sera d'aider non pas uniquement des
mesures de cours ou de moyen terme mais
des résumés des mesures de
transformation notre économie dans une
économie moins carbonée une une économie
à plus numérisé plus robotisée plus
relocalisez' aussi à un moment donné
c'est très important
la dimension sociale et les majeures il
faut donc insister là dessus je compte
la dimension sociale elle est
fondamentale elle peut être fondamental
dans l'idée d'égalité des chances
on voit bien que les français
aujourd'hui sont moins à égalité qui ne
l'était à une période dans les chances
qu'ils ont progressé dans la vie et
notamment dans la vie sociale très
important pour les jeunes nombre
d'études et nombre de prix nobel
d'économie le dise donc prenons ces
prenons des mesures qui permettent
d'engager la france verra mieux
écologique et vers un mieux sociale
maintenant la chasse aux riches
ça a toujours été le cas surtout dans
notre pays alors parfois on les chasse
tout doucement on ajoute les apports de
trouver leur coupe la tête je rappelle
que le riche c'est souvent votre voisin
le récit est celui qui gagne 100 200
euros plus c'est celui qui a une plus
jolie voiture
bon tout ça c'est pas une bonne manière
me semble-t-il de sortir d'une crise
surtout dans un pays qui est le premier
pays à hauteur fiscalisés au monde
quand on ajoute les charges fiscales
vers les impôts et les cotisations
sociales
donc c'est une option qui me semble
interdite alors on peut toujours avoir
un concours lépine permanent de la
fiscalité et comment augmenter la
fiscalité demain on officialisera les
portes et les fenêtres ou autre chose
on trouvera toujours non je pense que il
faut pas toucher à la fiscalité
il faut sans doute probablement orienter
la fiscalité en fonction de ce qu'on
souhaite
on pourrait réfléchir à une fiscalité
sur les entreprises qu'ils soient
différentes selon qu'elles êtes un
programme
de lutte contre l'émission carbone ou
pas voilà il ya beaucoup de sujets qui
peuvent être abordés de cette façon là
une façon me semble-t-il beaucoup plus
intelligente par des mois le temps
presse ont admiré par des questions
politiques et notamment à les élections
municipales sur l'élection à paris
qu'est ce que doit faire rachida dati
pour gagner et ce qu'elle doit s'allier
avec agnès buzyn de la république en
marche
hossa rachid el bien plus compétentes
que moi pour le dire tout ce que je sais
c'est qu'elle doit gagner voilà jeu et
il peut gagner je sais bien qu'on place
la maire sortante comme favorite mais
rachida et est pas très loin et je pense
qu'elle peut elle peut gagner ses dépens
des électeurs qui se mobiliseront il ya
évidemment du côté daniel guzman une
énorme pagaille politique on ne sait
plus trop bien ce que représente cette
crise qui a connu beaucoup de
vicissitudes
il faudrait pas que ce soit des votes
perdus donc ses électeurs ils doivent
vous savez il ya une formule c'est le
vote utile
il ya un moment donné il ya quelqu'un
qui est au pouvoir qu'est ce que vous
voulez de madame dati ou est ce que vous
voulez de madame hidalgo l'amygdale go
montrer quand même un certain nombre
d'imperfections dans la gestion de paris
donc votons et votez votez rachida dati
sur ces élections municipales la droite
et la gauche ont plutôt fait de bons
scores au premier tour ces élections
elles font renaître le clivage droite
gauche ancien du monde politique il est
patient c'est que ça il est déjà
totalement actuelle dans la propre
majorité et la majorité elle est déjà
dans un clivage droite gauche au fond
c'est pas anciens le monde il se partage
et bien il se partage pas en deux entre
le noir et le blanc le bleu et le rouge
non mais c'est plus et plus c'est
probablement plus sophistiqué que cela
mais il ya quand même une vision de
droite vision conservatrice une vision
républicaine une vision démocrates enfin
quel que soit le nom de la de la droite
et de la gauche
il ya des vision un peu différente nous
on a une vision très forte de
de l'homme de la dignité de l'homme du
respect de l'homme etc
on a aussi une vision économique qui
permet d exprimer cette cette dignité
on a une vision territoriale on a une
vision déjà commises et si je peux dire
en tout cas décentralisée de la gestion
du pays on doit l'exprimer les
républicains sont en train de travailler
là-dessus d'arrache-pied les élections
municipales sont en tout cas le premier
tour a été un succès pour notre
formation politique j'espère que ce sera
confirmé au deuxième tour si beaucoup
eric woerth d'avoir été à notre invité
politique dans notre émission bonjour
chez vous demain en plateau nous
recevrons la ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire elizabeth